minister it's quite fitting that we're
here in a gladiator's ring because
you've got quite a fight on your hand in
terms of climate change
india and china the world's first and
third biggest emitters have not
committed to net zero by 2050 president
biden hasn't got his deal signed off in
congress i'd put it to you you'll fight
in a losing battle well the the whole of
humanity uh beth is in the ring and the
foes of of humanity are uh apathy and
political indifference and lack of will
and
people's excessive caution about what
they can achieve those are the the foes
that we all collectively face and
actually i think that we can still do it
i think there is a there is a chance if
everybody puts their minds to it that we
can
get a
an agreement that will
allow us to restrain the growth in
temperatures we're not going to stop
climate change you said on the plane
that we were 5-1 down at half time yeah
that's bad odds what are you putting the
odds on that's 20 percent i mean do you
really think it's still six out of ten
chance of getting this done i think it's
going to be very difficult do you still
think six hours i think there's a chance
i think there's a chance what we can do
is get uh an agreement that the cot 26.
what odds do you put on 50 it's about
the same 60 it's about the same as it
was that's quite optimistic given what's
happening with the three biggest
admitters
let's see where we get to and the
pressure is is huge but what people need
to do is see the the scale of the risk
and you know you you talk about the uh
the place that we're in i think you're
quite right uh this vividly reminds us
of what happens when civilizations
miscalculate and then history actually
goes under the president goes into
reverse you spoke to president xi
yesterday is you giving him a red card
i i had a good conversation with the the
chinese with president xi and i think
that china has made a huge amount of
progress in in some ways we need him to
move so quickly
on stopping overseas
committing without them increasing their
targets
the whole thing collapses it's true
isn't it uh what we want to see is more
progress from lots of countries lots of
countries and what i said to president
xi is that it is possible to move away
faster from coal than china is currently
thinking
the uk did it when i was well i told
president xi when i first went to
beijing as mayor of london we had 50
minutes 40 of our energy came
just in terms of brexit france disputes
with france on fishing and eu on brexit
are you on the cusp of two trade wars
one with the eu over northern ireland
border and one with the french
overfishing
we're very keen to work with our friends
and partners on all these issues uh if
if if the
another european country wants to break
the the tca then we will we'll the trade
cooperation then obviously we'll have to
take steps to protect uk interests we
have that's absolutely are you going to
listen to dispute settlements
are you going to launch a dispute
settlement with france next week if
there's a if there's a breach of the
treaty or we think there's a breach of
the treaty of course do you think
there's a breach of the treaty
do you think that's a breach of the
treaty to protect british interests but
i am concerned here today do you think
there's been a breach of the treaty
i'm worried that there might be i'm
worried that there might be and and i'm
looking at what's going on at the moment
and you know i think that we need to
sort through so you can't rule it out
right you won't trigger that mechanism
is that is frankly
uh
small beer
or trivial by comparison with the threat
to humanity just to be clear you're not
you're not ruling out that you might
trigger the mechanism next week no of
course not i don't rule that out but but
what i think
everybody that wants to see is
cooperation between the the european
powers and emmanuel macron and i share
uh share a common perspective which is
that climate change is
a a disaster for humanity and and that
we have the tools to tackle it france's
basis huge progress
because i've got 30 seconds left and i
just want to put what your good friend
as you described on the plane so said
about you yesterday to the financial
times he said britain's credibility's on
the line over brexit and fishing he said
make no mistake it's not just for the
europeans but for all their partners the
uk's partners when you spend years
negotiating a treaty then a few months
later you do the opposite of what was
decided it's not a big sign
which is the point i would make with in
all humility and sincerity to all our uh
our friends and partners uh you know we
want to see that treaty observe but in
the meantime so you think he's not
observing in the meantime
i think the
much more important issues before us
before uh world leaders
today and in the next few days is how to
come together set an example to the
whole world about how we tackle climate
change make those nationally determined
uh contribution commitments show that we
can cut coal show that we can end our
dependence on hydrocarbon cars and and
and give the developing world the cash
it needs to fix it we can fix it but the
lesson of history is that things can go
badly wrong and stay wrong for a long
time